we were just chatting during the break
and and you mentioned that you do a
little trick you do this at parties what
do you where do you do it no i did it
when i was a little kid i want to see
this because it's like a special talent
i have okay
so you take the needle and thread and
pretend you have to pretend then you go
in take the thread out then you sew your
mouth
right so
the thing and comes out
and then you go
can you do that no that was very nice
i think it's more fun when you do it
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
you do lots of tricks like that yeah i
can do all sorts of things with my mouth
i was hoping you would give me a job
doing that mouth thing with the
president
okay if you want that yeah he's the face
and how long you know you want to do it
the pain ain't that great and you seem
to be doing fine without it but you're
more than welcome now you know what's
interesting is the timing of this movies
is uh kind of cool because a lot of
people now have a renewed interest in in
studio 54. i grew up in boston i was
never around studio 54 i didn't go to
that club so i don't know what it would
have been like if i had gone oh really
yeah well there was like tons of people
out trying to get in it was crazy i mean
everybody was killing to be in that
place because like the most important
and most beautiful and most outrageous
people would go there and so people
would stand outside and and
if you got picked you could go in but if
you didn't get picked you were screwed
you couldn't go and i i'm sorry conan
but i i don't know that you would have
gotten in because you're gonna look
like an accountant yeah that's kind of
like
well she's right i'm not like the
coolest looking guy i think if i was
could i please enter i would
i would appreciate it
i could come in i don't think yeah but
you know what now that it's coming back
in case they open another club like this
right i want to give you as a present
the studio 54 emergency kit
okay yeah they told me that you brought
some stuff that's back here
what are we talking about here we're
talking about a makeover
and this has to come off
oh this microphone has to oh okay and
this has to come up i'm liking this part
yeah
okay
all right we have to take off these the
whole tie has to go
okay the whole shrimp has to go actually
uh no wait you take the whole shirt off
yeah the whole shirt oh i didn't know
that no one wants to see my bear flash
on tv
[Applause]
i'm confused about why a couple of guys
actually like yeah oh come on come on
it's gotta come off
and it's a real treat for everyone out
there this is perfect for the period
this is gonna work okay this chest hair
on the chest works perfect it was very
in back then
okay now
here we go okay right in here what are
you putting it now right in here oh
great yeah this is terrific nice look
for me no we switched over this mic are
we cool all right now i have to do this
a special way
how do we do it
[Applause]
wait wait we're not done that's it i'd
meet a lot of nice fellas this way i
think yeah
here you go not bad
okay who's buying this right now you
like this look is this
[Applause]
you are ready to do the math do you
think you can get some bomb music for us
[Applause]
[Music]
you